la première fois qu'on était reçu depuis
le 10 janvier annonce de cette réforme
c'est bien tard en fait en vrai on
l'avait demandé bien plus tôt alors on y
va rétorqué qu'il y avait eu des
contacts informels il y a eu très peu de
contacts informel si ce n'est quelques
coups de fil de temps en temps et
notamment de la première ministre aux
responsables des organisations
syndicales
clairement je crois qu'on a eu une
interse syndicale depuis le début qui a
su faire la démonstration de ses
capacités de mobilisation massives des
salades les travailleurs et
travailleuses de ce pays et de ça en
unité
une nouvelle fois aujourd'hui on a
réclamé ensemble que les 60 fois 64 ans
soient pas une réalité ne s'applique pas
pour les travailleurs étrangers de ce
pays une fois qu'on a tous lancé tous
s'exprimer on a finalement demandé à la
première ministre de de confirmer si
elle retirait cette réforme comme nous
demandions tout et tout ça la réponse
est non vous comprenez bien
que les sujets d'usure au travail de
salaire d'emploi des seniors sont des
questions extrêmement importantes mais
qui sont corrélées au sujet des
retraites pourquoi n'a pas avoir
commencé par cela dans une formule de
conférence sociale je ne sais quoi
lorsqu'il était temps au mois d'octobre
c'est pas ce à quoi a répondu le
gouvernement il y a d'abord eu cette
réforme et nous ne nous ne passerons pas
outre le fait que il y a des millions de
salariés qui se mobilisent aujourd'hui
et une 90% de la population qui rejette
cette réforme des retraites et donc la
responsabilité à laquelle nous avons
appelé la sagesse à laquelle nous avons
appelé c'est de ne pas appliquer cette
réforme de la retirer
ce qui va se passer
je crois qu'on est en train on est en
train de vivre une grave crise
démocratique et on avait une crise
sociale qui se transforme en crise
démocratique mais je crois que personne
ne peut être surpris de les positions
des organisations syndicales nous
l'avons dit dès le départ et moi
qu'un second qui est 250 000 personnes
dans la rue depuis 10 manifestations
tout le monde dirait mais c'est un échec
finalement cette réforme elle ne cause
pas de contestation ce n'est pas la
réalité l'opinion n'a pas bougé depuis
même c'est accentué contre cette réforme
depuis début janvier le nombre de
personnes de travailleurs mobilisées et
toujours aussi importants et comment ça
pesait sérieusement dans le
porte-monnaie de nos collègues mais il y
a toujours une même détermination et on
le verra encore demain et donc la
sagesse dans une démocratie c'est
d'écouter à défaut de l'avoir fait
suffisamment avant d'écouter la
démocratie sociale et de se remettre
autour de la table cette proposition là
nous l'avons faite encore aujourd'hui
certains d'entre nous se sont dit on dit
ben on se remet autour de la table
la réponse c'est on se remet autour de
la table mais on continue comme si de
rien n'était sur les retraites la
réponse de la CFDT et des autres
organisations syndicales c'est non
professionnel valide la réforme
tout à l'heure au nom de la terre
syndicale à la sagesse du Conseil
constitutionnel qui va évidemment juger
en droit il y a aussi une question de
jugement en opportunité je crois que
la responsabilité du Conseil
constitutionnel qu'on nous respectons et
nous mettons pas sous pression c'est pas
notre responsabilité mais c'est
d'entendre aujourd'hui que notre
démocratie a besoin d'apaisement et que
l'apaisement ce serait que ce texte ne
s'applique pas
on a bien compris que cette idée de
médiation et de suspension avait été
balayé d'un revers de main à peine deux
heures après que nous l'ayons formulé
après en avoir discuté en inter
syndicale
évidemment que c'est cette idée de
suspendre et de se remettre autour de la
table pour discuter du travail si les 64
ans ne sont pas promulgués appliqués ça
restera intéressant mais c'est pas
aujourd'hui on nous a dit non donc
puisque on nous a dit non ben on va on
passe à l'autre option qui est la
question du retrait
bah écoutez demain moi j'en appelle
alors qu'il est après cette réunion j'en
appelle à ce que maximum de travailleurs
et de travailleuses de citoyens dans ce
pays rejoignent les cortèges partout en
France demain c'est de ça dont il s'agit
effectivement il faut qu'on démontre la
force de la démocratie sociale et dans
le calme sans violence ce qu'on appelle
à ce qu'un maximum de travailleurs et
travailleuses se mobilise je vous
remercie